[Music]
now
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait first can we do the slushie because
that'll give us some energy the slushy
poke slushy
what yeah we're doing we're drinking
right now yeah dude
coke
dude what kind of slushies do you got
for us so this is by the way this is our
[__]
thursday this is our thirsty thursday
yeah so first we're gonna
look at the tick tocks setting up the
slushies
okay let's watch them vicky thursday
sounds like a stripper name
[Music]
is he pouring that into his fleshlight
what is that
what [__] cup is that no one's
answered that
that looks like a fleshlight dude it is
that's what we're doing we're drinking
coke out of a fleshlight today
[Music]
isn't this kind of sick though what you
can [__] that thing
this thing's squeezing
[Music]
yeah there's air coming out of that
are you smelling it
[Laughter]
a good queef air
stop all right
all right what's in the slushy cup
slushy cup
this is disgusting dude
no it looked like a frozen fleshlight
yeah this is how many people do you
think have [__] this and then squeeze
the ice around their deck this is what
you put your dick into after you use a
[__] ring
what the [__] is going on here
okay
so you pour the liquid in yeah
right right
and then you just squeeze it and it like
fills it with ice squeeze it for about
like a minute what it's got to freeze it
my hands are all it doesn't freeze
doesn't it like just disperse ice into
it
it's basically like a ice pack
this is the dumbest [__] we've ever done
oh make a icee with the cool
slushy is this a prank or are we just
squeezing flashlights right now i put
too much in there so it's like i can't
squeeze too much you gotta put the lid
on oh
is that it
holy [__] this actually works
that's actually pretty sick that's
actually pretty sick that's actually
pretty sick
just squeeze it like this and then you
gotta carve you [__] oh whatever this
carpet sucks
[Music]
and
voila oh oops
wow
okay this is kind of working
this is actually pretty sick
no
i'm not i'm not gonna say it's sick
because i don't support this but
why don't you support it
because it's weird
this is like one of those classic like
like just
e-commerce products that they get off
alibaba this is the new form of drop
shipping you know yeah it is yeah this
is what people do now
they find real like tick-tock-able [__]
on alibaba and they all they do is
marketing on tick-tock and now shopify
is building
uh e-commerce into tick-tock so you can
actually buy this [__] directly in the
app
where did you get this
oh off slushiecup.com
kyle
they're probably making gajillions of
dollars off this [__] and people use it
once and then go this is
weird
this is really good
[Music]
what am i doing
this podcast was about discussion and it
just devolved into this like what is
happening right now
this is the only place where you can
hear like a serious in-depth discussion
discussion
discussion in depth discussion
[Laughter]
in-depth in-depth discussion
like the frozen apple juice in the
little plastic cup
i never got a concussion in high school
it was like this little cup of
martinelli's
it was [__] apple juice
you get your head hit on the [__]
playground and that's the [__] they'd
give you check your temperature
what
eat some
this is man
this [__] is actually really [__]
good oh my god
wait let me try again
oh my god that's ice
do you hear this
[Laughter]
i was gonna say this is the only podcast
where in 20 minutes it can go from
serious
conversations about finding about just
this
i'm feeling loopy now is that not good
an apple juice slushy that sounds really
[__] good the stuff they would feed
you after you got like your head hit by
a handball
getting nailed to the tetherball you're
like
there's a little cup folded with this
[__] like have that
why
because you're like too brain dead to
eat real yeah
that should get you feeling right
yeah i don't know
yeah when would who would use this twice
i just did
no but
you're gonna take this home and use it
again oh no this is going straight in
the trash
the spoon doubles as a straw too no way
that's so cool
[Laughter]
yeah hey it doubles as a straw
it tastes like a 7-eleven coke smoothie
you know i'm just i'm just wondering
what would it feel like
that's what i'm saying you know i just
gotta bust a nut in this thing and see
if it makes it curious
oh yeah yeah that's cold
and then wait wait
hold on just one second
hold on
no damn it it's not working anymore
never mind oh [__] it never mind i'm an
idiot
all right this podcast sucks okay
between these two this is your brain
when the earth burns up this is evidence
of why we deserved it you know what
send it in
the lord whoever's up there just send it
down
all the hot
i'm done yeah
this is a fire could you imagine as i
said that an asteroid hit this thing
just send it down god
i'll be stoked
you're really getting energized off this
man i could feel it
i mean
that was really good
yeah
all right what's next
you